na gut dann kann es zumindest mal keiner
mit pfeilen kaputt machen
das wird sich zeigen was war das denn
was für einen kranken hund
jo leute an alle sg 2 herzlich
willkommen wir sind hier die games
hardware online spiel und erste
gäste-chance mir gar nicht
herausgenommen hat da hab ich mir gar
nichts raus genommen so heißt es die ja
ich hab s serie die pid wir zocken
energie ich gesagt hat heute bin ich mal
alleine hier weil ich mal zeigen mir
glaube ich alleine auch alle station
kann er nämlich sonst nix
sonst hätte ich wahrscheinlich so
alleine jetzt dafür brauchen wir so ein
bisschen holz hat ist ja klar
übrigens sollte der drei ks und das p53
karl grenze ist bald erreicht
ich freue mich richtig drauf und jetzt
ist es ganz wichtig ich werde in die
beschreibung dieses videos ja wenn ich
meinen twitter-account packen und es ist
ganz wichtig dass jeder der beim 3
kassierte dabei sein will diesen account
vorlaut also abonniert auf twitter das
ist ganz wichtig denn ich werde darunter
auf twitter wenn ich alle ansagen machen
zu solchen sachen wie ja wo wo ich wurde
special stattfindet und so weiter ein
bisschen der betankung es weitergehen
und ja da führt ist es ganz wichtig dass
ihr eben auch auf twitter geht in diesem
kabinett damit wir uns dann abstimmen
können ich werde dann auch so machen zb
mein glaube spielt sandler games in
diesem moment so wie jetzt hier ein
wenig so machen ja leute ich habe auf
twitter ja in der games kommt mal alle
in 16 oder so und dann kommt ihr halt
alle dahin
und dann ist alles gut so machen wir das
dann also so ist meine planung und hat
natürlich ganz geil wenn ihr damit
spielen würde weil sonst kann man ja
nicht wirklich funktionieren oder es
wird sicher cool also ich freue mich auf
jeden fall drauf damit euch bisschen bis
hinab zu gehen könnte reisen sprechen
verzaubern
ich konnte nicht mehr klar da haben sie
einfach das eisen strecken zu machen
muss den bogen verzaubern mit einem
bogen mit radfahren kann es auch nichts
zu essen essen alters ist eine scheiße
und es ist doch so ein müll harry in
einem einfach das schwert geklaut wird
es um fest schlimmste so was tut man
caspar aber mach ich super gerne mache
jetzt erstmal weiter müssen sie ein paar
ändert es diesmal aber vielleicht den
nächsten gegnern ausweichen
ich habe jetzt keinen bock neben gold
auch nicht schaden zu machen allergie
leggewie satan
das alter ist immer geil hatte der
irgendwas zum zweiten versuch mal ein
eisen schwert vielleicht wird ja diesmal
was das zaubern
er schafft noch selber oder schiff
dessen leben von diners und ich hier
nichts zu essen findet ja keiner
größter coup
da unten
wo gott wenn man sich zu wenig leben und
hätte nichts zu essen dabei alter [ __ ]
zu regenerieren nicht alter schwede
das ist jetzt wirklich nicht geil schaaf
ich will dich nicht du scharf ich kann
kein eisen essen was essbares essen kein
schaf schwein wird es noch richtig
schönes steak machen welche richtig bock
drauf komme jetzt ohne scheiß wo sind
hier die fucking schweine oder schicken
ich würde ja sogar schicken nehmen na ja
auch kein ding heute kann ich meine
ender perle wie zum beispiel sofort weg
bin vor
da kommt der typ nicht mal woanders hin
und er ist uns hinterher
hunde schafe die kann man nicht es sind
leute das ist nicht geil was anderes vor
als leckerer snack ich bin so glücklich
bin so glücklich
nein das kann es doch nicht sein dass
wir das nächste schreiben
kampf ungeschlagen als zwei new yorker
direct group
das ist perfekt
ich finde ich jetzt mal wenn es kein
problem ist doch kein problem
das war ne sk der grillmeister und sind
auf die ohren
ja die gar kein thema
sollte jetzt können wir das mal wieder
ein bisschen zweiten hier das noch nicht
ja vielleicht machen uns und wir können
unsere sache entscheiden habe ich traue
dem braten nicht ist schon eine weile
her seitdem ist jetzt mal geortet werden
da kann ich gleich die nächste bord wie
man natürlich nicht so groß sein und
gerade sachen im entscheidenden match
entscheiden
ist doch scheiße doch keiner läuft bei
uns noch romans push oder hennef
da wirklich möchte aber nicht horst
richtiger sport dieses label 1 sack und
videoprojekte protection ja gut dann
kann es zumindest mal keiner mit pfeilen
kaputt machen
das wird sich zeigen
was war das denn was für einen kranken
hund
du musst sterben der andere wurde der
andere zum hund angegriffen
ich weiß gar nicht okay es gibt noch
viele leute hatten keine chance bot sich
dieser hund einfach durch die luft alter
macht mich nicht schwach
yesterday leistung von philipp und
meiner maus gehabt irgendwie bisschen
probleme gab die zu greifen
aber ich habe nicht mein angebot von
amazon abgesehen von vorne gesehen
wollen wir nicht das wollen wir nicht
das wollen wir nicht
bis element aus der teams immer gut hat
er irgendwas sinnvolles gebracht so
eisen weisen mäßig er tendiert heute
verzaubert verzaubert es war noch nicht
erwartet ok wenn das thema jetzt archiv
vornehmen doch becks ich noch weg ist
nicht gut nach b will keiner übrigens
wie sollten die nba und menükarten es
über 25 mal 24 beiden spieler wie teilt
3004 unten nicht und michaela wie take
that were correct at time bisschen ich
habe nicht so blauäugig kann ich ein
bisschen mehr vertragen erzählt bis im
mehrwerte ganz nice ganz normal ich bis
zum berg widmen
jetzt wird's dunkel dem rad ein bisschen
probleme mit mit dem genie aber meist
relativ hell und direkt dahinter das
fenster da schon die sonne rein und dann
ist hier mein kopf zu tun könnten
egal macht sinn firefight barbara
letzter freiheit ev
da drüben
was hat der verein hervor
hinter dem baum
das heißt nicht so gar nicht so billig
gekämpft bleibt doch stehen ich will ich
will ich doch noch weniger nachteile
hätten switcher geworfen gutermuth was
jetzt nein
jähriger bub das war der energiemix
damals data protection sachen uns doch
mal was geholfen
fette sache auf jeden fall erstmal hier
in müll
das war es also wie gesagt
twitter-account ist in der beschreibung
unbedingt voll und für das dreieck a
special
damit wir da zusammen zocken können und
zusammen die gelder zeit an können und
so richtig ablegen weiß bescheid war
sondern mit ihr portal sein kann damit
wir unseren schnauze halten können aber
auch besser schreiben dies das wisst ihr
bescheid also leute wie gesagt noch mal
auf twitter followen da können wir unser
special machen das wäre richtig geil
und da würde ich sagen macht's gut leute
ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen tag
und hat rein